what's up it's your favorite girl Cali
catch me on a bootleg Kev podcast
yo it's the bootleg cab show we got a
special guest in here representing ATL
Cali is here gotta say like Cali Cali
yeah and you have a white boy in your
roster
I guess I do
that's great yeah you know I'm just all
about representation sometimes yeah and
I know we have a lot of that in the
world but I just feel like it's nice to
see like women who aren't that don't
look like my Aunt claiming white boys
you know yeah I know a lot of people are
like dang why did she say that I'm like
cause y'all need y'all moments we need a
moment you gave it to us so I appreciate
that thank you do you literally have a
white guy on your roster at all or have
you ever been with a white dude
um no I don't have a white boy on my
roster right now but um when I was in
high school I this was the only way I
thought was super cute he was so
handsome but I don't know you never like
no wow
that's crazy she never even gave us a
chance just it's just great for the
lyrics I mean yeah
um
yeah you know they say once you go white
you'll be all right you know what I mean
I never heard that in my entire life
once you go by Ubi that's so funny
um this is that yeah first of all the
area code song is pretty crazy it's very
um
yeah I feel like your songs are very
like
they're very like free yeah I mean it's
straight to the point and straight to
the point
um what was the inspiration to do your
version of area codes
um
um I just felt like the girls needed a
summer Anthem and if you didn't have
hoes if you don't have hoes now you've
had hoes before okay you know what I'm
saying I just feel like a lot of people
could relate to that yeah and I also
feel like it's nice to see like the
double standard being broken down yeah
because I feel like it's all right for
women to have hoes as well as you know
vice versa but I feel like if a dude
says it it's like more celebrated and
yeah because then we just get called
hoes but you know if you just I like I
said in the song you just get the money
and you and you go or you be outside you
have fun and go home yeah uh
did you see this clip of this lady who
said that she wouldn't date uh I forget
her name she was just on The Breakfast
Club but she was talking about
they asked if she would date a
a bus driver and she said only if he
owned the bus
and there was controversy because she
said she wouldn't date a bus driver
unless he owned the bus like why would
he be driving the bus if he owns it my
thing is though right is I feel like for
a lot of working class guys out here who
maybe just have a normal nine to five
maybe they have a warehouse job maybe
they work at Amazon maybe they're
delivering packages to your door it
feels like
uh there's like a a narrative being
pushed amongst the more popular women in
our culture that you know that might not
be enough these days what do you think
about like you know would you ever give
a normal guy a chance
um like a guy who made less money than
you
probably probably not like it's just you
know that's
cool for somebody else what if he's got
a plan now
no
said because like men like to get up
they like to get up and then dip on the
person that was there when they was you
know coming up so I'd rather just just
hit me when to come up happening so the
come-ups already asked to either have
taken place or it's in the works like
you next week you know the checks in the
clear life
other than that I'm sorry and that's no
shade like that's just for me like if I
I feel like I want to feel like secure
and you know
I need the man that's supposed to
provide that's just how I feel so so you
so you like double standards when it
comes to that that's true yeah so you
wouldn't provide for a man
if you were in love
absolutely not I'm not gonna be in love
with you what if you did listen listen
what if you date a lawyer right he's
really rich you fall in love you're
madly in love with him your career goes
crazy the lawyer gets disbarred yeah
okay in that circumstance that I got you
he's flat on his ass I got you
but you gotta you gotta have a plan to
get that you know back in Action now I I
feel that but off the bat it's like no
okay I respect that yeah I respect the
honesty yeah
um you gotta album on the way I know you
dropped the album a couple years ago
I don't have no album on the way but I'm
dropping singles I just did some
Regional remixes with a couple people
like I saw you did the sped up version
of this song which seems to be like
everyone's got the like yeah the like
Club Music version of their songs like
the Jersey type of vibe going on yeah
that's that's going crazy on Tick Tock
but I did some remixes with uh Lakayla
from the bay
and I did one with Kenzo bishes from New
York I'm doing one with little Tyler
coming up and yeah he's so he's so cool
and he's a kid and I was in it I was in
a nightclub with him recently
and I just looked over and I was like
why are you supposed to be here I like
Googled it in the club I was like
oh he's I think he's 16 or 17. yeah he's
not 18 or you're not even 18. I was like
why is he in here because he's cool
right he gang so you already did that
version yeah well it hasn't dropped yet
but it's on the way and then uh sexy red
I did one with her too it's coming so
I'm trying to that's got to be a very
very uh provocative song no actually
it's not provocative she was just
talking her her ones I'm interviewing
her today really yeah okay yeah we
sexy red she's a
she's free yeah we love we love the
girls that's free I saw her running
around spring break with the breasteses
out I said hey
are you a fan of Pound Town do you like
this yes yeah I love found town
yeah it's a it's a good song yeah
I feel like you do like like you're you
because I think about like some of your
bigger records and they are very like
they're very uh I think that the it
gives me like OG Trina Vibe sometimes
yeah which I feel like has been kind of
missing in in well not really [__] was
kind of that you know but but it kind of
gets did you grow up listening to Trina
at all uh yes and some in some music
yeah who are you bumping as a as a
youngin
um I I like r b Vibes I feel like I was
like listening to like Janae Aiko Okay
and like
um Aaliyah Missy Elliott Vibes like this
was my vibes when you were a kid you
were listening to Janae yeah I'm so old
man
how old are you 22. [__]
what year is that that you were born
2000 I gotta tell you the right huh
oh my God yeah I remember two thousand I
thought what was you doing in 2000 [__]
thinking the world was gonna end at my
uncle's house on New Year's Eve
wait no there was a time in 2020 Y2K
thing that was like a thing like you you
wouldn't know but
when 1999 was happening they said when
the clock hit 2000 like all the
computers and [__] in the world were
gonna like freeze up and like the world
was gonna like end see they that it was
a time in 2012 but they said the same
thing and I was I was 12. and like they
were like it's going to be this big
storm and all this stuff so it was
actually raining that day so I was
having a panic attack like the world is
overweight I'm only 12. it's coming yeah
isn't there a movie called 2012. I think
there's a movie yeah really
yeah yeah that's what it was that's what
it was what is your sign
I'm a Leo see I don't know what any of
this means so you just asked it didn't
you so I'm I'm I know I just know I'm an
aquarius okay
look where's they get along well we get
along yeah
we Scorpios what months are that like I
don't even know I don't I don't pay
attention scorpions but when you say
you're a Scorpio it's like is Drake a
Scorpio no Drake's a Libra no
I think he put it out October 23rd to
November 21st yeah I think he is Scorpio
any Scorpios in here
nope okay that's good
so if you are like let's say you go out
on a date with a guy and you find out
he's a Scorpio is that a wrap
yeah we probably didn't even get along
during the day what if you did get along
and like everything was going great and
then he was like I was born on October
24th and then you're like
yeah they're just full of [__] so
probably really yeah they're sneaky like
it probably went so great and I probably
think the world is like peaches and
creams with them but I just know deep
down there full of [__] really yeah I
you know I didn't know that this existed
like you would like discriminate against
someone you liked because of their I
mean I mean they can't choose that yeah
it depends um
I guess it depends huh it depends on how
good it was like how good the date was I
might consider okay okay okay yeah
that's fair uh well listen man uh shout
out to all the Scorpios out there just
know she will discriminate against you
yeah and very bad and if you work at
Amazon you're [__]
Amazon Ambia Scorpio that's the double
whammy I might just walk past you uh
what what do you do in your free time
right now you've like streaming TV are
you uh working out are you playing video
games what do you do when you're on like
when you're not recording or running
around the country pushing your music
um I'm getting into like I love to cook
so I'm trying to start my own little
like cooking
I don't know is it like the reels and
the shows and stuff yeah I'm trying to
you know start doing that and I have a
dog we just be at the house
my t-shirt too oh like a little a little
puppy his name is Chase Chase yeah like
that uh what do you cook like what's
your go-to dish
uh I so it's so funny because I put in a
song uh pasta Lobster but it's actually
like my go-to dish now like so the
lobster pasta is what your go-to is yeah
you gotta try it it's so good can you
cook up like any special sort of ramen
noodles like if you were to make a pack
of noodles yeah and you put like the egg
and the shrimp
and like the green onions and stuff it's
like
it's like chicken enough some people
will put like uh just hot sauce and like
melted cheese and cheese yeah you never
put cheese in your noodles
y'all put cheese in y'all noodles
I do oh no
you just put like uh so look the you
know is it like a single cheese slice it
could be
friend I don't like that and then look
and then you just stir it and then it
melts into the noodles
I don't like that food then you get
Tapatio hot sauce then some soy sauce
it's soy sauce too yeah and then you put
the beef pack in
and and a little bit of butter
I swear to God I swear to God it's good
I swear that sounds horrible
it sounds like prison
it sounds like spread it is funny
because like I didn't know
subconsciously as a kid I was just
making spread the whole time until I
started to see these rappers put
together their spreads and I was like I
was eating that when I was a kid
shout out to my parents let me eat like
a [__] convict when I was 11. I'm
still trying to figure out what a spread
is so when you're in jail they'll
they'll take like because you know in
jail there's like limited stuff you can
get your hands on right so they'll take
like noodles they'll take like sardines
or tuna they'll just put a bunch of [__]
together and then they'll mash it
together
right and then they'll cook it and then
it's like a they call it a spread I went
to jail for four days why
because I didn't show up to court and it
was on Memorial Day weekend so so
everybody was on vacation yeah what was
that like and they it was like a it was
actually in Douglasville Georgia and so
like they had everybody
like I just had a failure to appear for
speeding nothing crazy nothing crazy but
I was in there with women that was about
to do 15 years right so it was not fun
I've been to jail twice it's not fun
either yeah now let me ask you this when
you went to jail
did you notice anybody using the roll of
toilet paper as a pillow in the holding
cell no
I don't think I wanted I don't think I
talked to anybody I just literally I
didn't eat yeah because you don't want
to [__] in front of everybody no I just
that looks disgusting no I didn't eat
either
they give you like a bag of peanut
butter no they didn't they didn't give
me none of that they gave me were you
even holding cell with a bunch of random
people yeah well it was just one other
person so I was in a holy cell with like
20 other dudes yeah
and I was like I am not [__] in here
so they gave you food I was like I need
nothing I took a roll of toilet paper
used it as a pillow in the corner and
just waited
it was terrible I don't like I don't
understand like when people go to jail
and they get out and then they go back
yeah it doesn't make sense yeah why did
it happen to you twice why why did you
go I go to jail the first time oh the
first time I went to jail was because I
uh I gave false information to a police
officer oh
and the second time I went to jail was
because uh the case is still open so we
won't talk about it okay okay okay well
cool but yeah it wasn't anything crazy
but uh yeah jail sucks yo what's good
man we gotta stop the interview to tell
you about our good Folks at my bookie
that's right man NBA season is uh
winding down playoffs are going down so
many ways you can get money you could
bet on who you think's gonna win the
finals you can get your prop bets per
game uh we are finally down to the final
eight right now uh my son's ain't
looking good at the time of recording
not looking good uh look go to
mybookie.ag right now sign up
I've been gambling on my Boogie for over
10 years so listen come and join me
let's get this money together
mybookie.ag when you use the promo code
bootleg when you sign up use that promo
code you're gonna get that deposit bonus
that deposit bonus is craziest the sign
up bonus you get and not only are
basketball football which is starting to
creep up on us baseball's back MLB
baseball man all season long you get
this money plus they got the online
casino if you're in the craps Blackjack
roulette [__] slot machines whatever
it is go to mybookie.ag right now use
that promo code bootleg and get that
free deposit bonus that's how we're
doing things all right also I want to
give a big shout out to the homies of
King Palm man these are our new sponsors
at King Palm now this is the thing about
these King poms man these things right
here
ah natural natural leaves free of
tobacco and additives the only thing I
smoke out of and what's dope is they got
these other ones right these uh this is
one of their more popular items right
here
great flavor
these are the leaf rolls they hold a
gram each and they got the terpene fused
tips which means you squeeze and you pop
the tip while you're smoking your flour
and you get a little burst of flavor
these are the peach pineapples
um they got the energy drink flavor they
got blue blueberry watermelon all kinds
of [__] man
um so what's dope if you go to
kingpom.com and use the promo code
bootleg Kev right now you're gonna get
half off half off
half off kingpom.com tobacco free
natural
wraps all right and also don't forget if
you're in a I don't know wherever you're
at go to 7-Eleven they got them your
local smoke shop one of the most
successful uh businesses in the game
when it comes to the all-natural Leaf
the most successful no tobacco no
nicotine just natural Leafs to stuff
your flour in and in case you did not
know they also have
whatever size King Palm this is this is
a giant Leaf wrapped around yeah wrapped
around some premium can I buy shout out
to uh King pump go follow one more time
kingpound.com promo code bootleg Kev say
50 off let's get back to the interview
and then they knew my music too at the
time
recently what was that last year
last Memorial
we've been doing a show or something
so okay so actually so this sounds so
funny because it was like I just said
when people go back so I've been there
twice but for the first time I was just
like only there for it no I was only
there for like a couple hours because I
had a show and my manager came and she
got me and that was the first time I was
like what the I'm never doing that again
like I hated that and when you spin the
block and then I went
I I just wasn't I had moved and I forgot
to change my address and I never got the
ticket yeah so they and I and I pulled
over and I was confident I'm like also
why am I being pulled over like I'm I'm
good was it one of the tickets where you
drove past the camera and it took a
picture of you or what did you get like
a no it was like
it was like a year a year ago and I was
like speeding on this like uh it was a
back road and nobody was driving there I
was just going to pick up my food was it
like a one of those Highway Patrol guys
just parked yeah and the lights was off
and they in the South I tell you what in
the South those [__] highway patrol
guys be camped out actually I did and
then he he came up screaming at the
window like do you know I could take you
to jail right now you guys are going
fast
yeah when you're like uh I was I can't
even like I'm like he really can't take
me to jail right now because like why
would you go that fast you know if you
gave a Postmates driver a chance you
wouldn't have to drive to get your own
food you just have your man do it he
would be kind of poor but you know
um
you know
yeah
yeah what's your preferred like uh
Cuisine if you were ordering food
um I like a filet mignon cooked medium
Jesus with a lobster tail and some
mashed potatoes 100 bucks every time on
Postmates yeah actually I I ordered I
actually ordered that with like the
cream corn and stuff this on the random
day what's under 20 that you would like
okay how about this what's your favorite
fast food chain Popeyes but they kind of
expensive now you ain't getting that
twenty dollars now what are you getting
at Popeyes are you getting a family meal
well if I'm ordering it from doordash
you know that oh yeah doordash they add
everything up that's fair that's fair
that's fair and I'm usually ordering it
from doing this so do you guys have
Raising Canes in Atlanta no well yeah no
it's in Athens Georgia and it's like two
hours away have you had it yeah it's
amazing amazing it's so good the sauces
but we have Zaxby's which is like a it's
like a yeah just like y'all have college
junior we have Hardies it's like well
that's literally the same thing Hardee's
and Carl's Jr is the same thing okay
it's the same company
I just thought it was no Zaxby's and
raising Kansas they're different but
they're the same at the same time yeah
yeah I mean
they have more options yeah but they do
yeah but they do have the same kind of
like sauce and the chicken tenders what
are your thoughts on McDonald's
McDonald's is still good to me I just
want to make sure we're on the same page
another cheeseburger you put fries in
your burger I used to I don't do that no
more just give me the fries with the
salt you gotta put the fries in the
burger no
why do you eat like that
it's so good you stuff the I get the
number nine it's two cheeseburgers then
you put the fries in the burgers there's
another way to do it and then you get
the McChicken the spicy McChicken for a
dollar they don't have that number they
don't got it where you're at they got it
where I'm at they don't got no spicy
made chicken in Atlanta they brought it
back
hey and they brought the orange High sea
back which is they got rid of it for
like a year I never really drank that
I'm more of like a fruit punch Coke yeah
well McDonald's Coke is uh you know it's
God's cocoa
okay if there is a God if there is a God
would drink McDonald's Coke
he wouldn't drink normal I thought it
was spray I thought this and the Sprite
okay it's both okay do you think do you
believe in aliens
yeah I don't think that we're the only
people like okay so let me ask you a
question
do you think if aliens came down and we
knew for sure they were aliens everybody
who was like extremely religious would
like their head would blow up like just
no I don't oh no I've never thought
about that hmm
shrooms yeah no my friend she she does
shrooms and she caught me one time and
she was like laying on a brown carpet
right and she was like
ah I'm in the sand like I'm sinking in
the sand I'm like what is wrong with you
like where are you she's like girl I
don't know what's wrong with me and I
was like I just don't want I like to be
in control and I feel like I that's just
the control is gone I don't know what
I'm doing you gotta do you start seeing
[__]
your friend was on some other [__] no
she wasn't though she might ate a lot
I don't she it's not like that was her
first time either
then she would tell you she ate a lot
she went in she put it on a honey bun
and it was oh yeah she went in she's a
real one where's she at
she have a white white boy on her roster
absolutely not
she said he's As Black As It Gets shout
out to her man
um
yo I don't know what's up do you your
family your parents I don't know your
you know if your parents are around or
not but when they hear your music what
do they think oh my mom she she'd be
turned up she like hell yeah yeah talk
that [__] yeah she be with it she know
every word that's amazing my dad he told
me he don't want to hear that I was
going to say your dad though is the real
yeah he he he's happy for me like he's
like oh I hear your mom tells me like
you're doing this and that but he's like
turn that out I don't want to hear my
daughter talking about that like right
has he been to a show no yeah but then
again my dad never went to a soccer game
oh but shout out to him though you got
problems like uh like dad issues a
little bit I had them in the past now I
just know you got over him yeah it's
like it's whatever that's fair I respect
that love him though shout out to Papa
shade shout out to Pops yeah I always
wonder like you know like if you have a
song like uh some of your records like
what's dad think or does he can he
listen no I don't think he's ever listen
you know like I have like a you know
there's like girls who have like only
fans accounts and I just wonder if like
their dad knows or if their dad's
friends know no one time I my dad never
seen my Instagram and this is before
like my mom didn't approve like what I
would be posting on Instagram and so she
caught him and was like
this is what your daughter posted on
Instagram so he was like I came in the
house one day and he was like sitting in
the chair like my dad is not serious at
all like I don't take him serious
whatsoever like I came in like laughing
like what are you doing he's like well
if you want to work for Playboy you know
not in my house and I'm just like Dad
leave me alone like really what an old
old dude reference yeah like nobody yeah
he's they don't even have naked women in
Playboy anymore the magazine is ruined
forever it's like a glorified he made it
seem like it was a bad thing like matter
of fact actually tell Playboy hit me up
actually you're right I want to be here
that's a check hey and you don't even
have to take your clothes off to being
Playboy that's what I'm saying he but he
don't know that he's just trying to be
funny and it just wasn't I was just like
man
watch the TV watch the TV for sure
what's the last show you uh binge
watched
um the last show I binge watched was
this is the show called Sirens Sirens
this is about mermaids
nice it's actually a really good show
y'all should try to watch it on
um Hulu Sirens about mermaids yeah I
like stuff like that like when I be
going on through Tick Tock and the
people be like mermaids are real I I
just saw one of those videos I like I
just go down a hole of just like trying
to figure out if they're really real
like I have to get to the bottom of it I
saw a video uh that looked like it was
horseshit but uh one of my friends
reposted it like this is wild and it's
like a someone took it from the side of
a boat and like you could see like a I
kind of see like a mermaid come in and
out of the water and I was like bruh
but he really he believed it yeah people
were people people in Jamaica like they
tell you like the mermaids are there
like it's a I forgot what it's called
but it's like a
a lake or something and so you think
mermaids are real yeah
I believe it how do they breathe
well we don't know you know I
should not even Discover it so how we
can't even go down to the bottom so am I
right so I'm sure it's plenty things we
don't know about so uh my mom's uncle
was one of the first employees at NASA
he died his name's Uncle doc rest in
peace
my mom asked him if aliens were real
this was like in the 90s she asked him
and he can't say [__] because I guess
his whole life is monitored but he said
I can't say that but what I will say is
if most people knew what was in the
ocean they'd want to kill themselves
yeah
see the land also because you have some
class nobody wants to go on a [__]
cruise ship if you have class yeah no
yeah true but
it's like that's my biggest fear of
being in the middle in the middle of the
water with a bunch of
yeah it's a bunch of Amazon employees oh
my God eating all inclusive meals hold
on we like the all-inclusive though me
too never too real for that never too of
course that's why I like going to Cancun
you go to Cancun I've never been to
Cancun
no so where do you get inclusive at I
went to Jamaica I got all inclusive it
was bomb I stayed on the overwater
Bungalows [__]
no my man was rich it is summertime if
you're dealing with elect erectile
dysfunction Ed if you will maybe you got
stress at work
maybe you're tired of looking at the
same chick
maybe you just need a little pep in your
step
um you need to get on that blue too man
you don't need to do anything but it'd
be nice to have the option to so go to
bluetooth.com right now
use the promo code bootleg and get the
first month supply of Bluetooth for free
what is Bluetooth
well Bluetooth is a chewable gets
delivered to your door in a discrete
package no doctor's appointments no
doctor's visits and uh it has the same
active ingredient as Viagra
and Cialis
so we're talking about getting your dick
hard here in case that went over your
head you know it won't go over your head
once you take it I promise you that all
right Bluetooth also is uh incredible
because not only does it come in the
blue chewable flavor with the same
active ingredient as vibrancy house but
it also has a mint chewable flavor which
is the same active ingredient as Levitra
all right all this if you're questioning
I don't know I don't want to spend no
money on does this [__] work look yes it
works and you don't have to spend money
if you use the promo code bootleg
at bluetooth.com because it's going to
get delivered right to your house
they're going to give you a month's
supply for free you just got to pay five
dollars shipping that's it the Bluetooth
come into your house no awkward doctor's
appointments
no awkward doctor's visits it's all
online
bluetooth.com Thank Me Later what's up
guys hey um if you are watching this and
it's April 20th 4 20.
I'm gonna be hanging out at hardean
today
that's right put the flyer up Little
Rock
I'll be at hardean um hanging out all
day today
um the craziest most just luxurious
illest dispensary in the world located
right in Los Vegas Nevada now Harding
Las Vegas they are our family they'd
sponsor the podcast I love those guys
dearly and when I say that it is the
best place I've ever walked into to buy
premium cannabis I'm not lying best
customer service
best bud tenders best bud
to put in your King Palm
and uh just overall man just a great
experience um so what you all need to do
is go follow them online hardeen
underscore Las Vegas follow them on the
gram
we got a lot of dope stuff in the works
they actually just opened a a fire
podcast studio so we're going to be
doing a lot of content in Vegas
live from hardeen they also just dropped
a [__] tennis shoe with Fila they got
dope flag gear
um man premium cannabis the best
selection
culture
sniff you walk in that man listen they
got I'm not even lying to y'all Harding
has their own signature scent and it
smells good I keep a bottle of it in my
car literally maybe twice a day I spray
get that hard eating whiff smells
amazing so look make sure you go to
hardine uh if you're in Vegas get in
that Uber get in that cab as soon as you
touch down say take me to hardine the
taxi drivers the Ubi drivers they know
exactly where it is because it's the
hottest spot in Vegas they go take you
straight there you're gonna tell them I
sent you they're gonna get you situated
real nicely all right Harding underscore
Las Vegas go show them some love go to
hardinglasvegas.com gotta give a shout
out to our oh geez my dogs had Odd Socks
baby they've been [__] with us from
day one
um and they've been dropping so many
crazy dope new like socks you know first
of all can we talk about Beavis and
Butthead they just dropped the Beavis
and Butt-head socks and draws let's take
a check just a nice little peek at the
Beavis and Butthead
drawskis bruh
oh
come on man
they also just dropped Coca-Cola we got
Scarface we got Reese's we got the big
[__] Lebowski so many dope socks the
most comfortable socks in the world the
most comfortable underwear in the world
and check this out right now you can get
20 off that's 20 off at checkout
at oddsoxofficial.com using the promo
code bootleg so go right now
otsoxofficial.com my first uh suggestion
would be get you a pair or a pack of the
Odd Socks Basics the black and the
whites those are my go-to's and then you
gotta [__] with some of these Big
Lebowski socks and they just got
Coca-Cola
they got the Scarface boys like what are
we talking about man what are you
waiting on they are the most comfortable
socks in the world
um so if you're not wearing Odd Socks
you're just cheating yourself you know
what I mean you're really cheating
yourself
they got [__] South Park
come on bruh what are we talking about
go to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg say 20 off at
checkout on the most comfortable socks
in the world or don't and keep torturing
yourself with those shitty socks you're
wearing right now
be a damn shame anyway let's get back to
the interview yeah that's my biggest
fear being stuck in the middle of the
ocean I can only imagine you have you
ever uh gotten flipped over on a jet ski
in the middle of the ocean yes I have
that's right and I had a heart attack
super scary I did I was on the back of a
jet ski having a blast I said don't go
fast and then yeah and then you're going
crazy when you're climbing up it's like
like it's a vulnerable position of your
life
oh my God where's the jet ski they like
that I can't swim like that so yeah no
flipping over on a dress I've done it a
lot and uh I always I sometimes I do it
on purpose with my wife I just flip that
[__] because she's like you should be
freaking the [__] out and then my makeup
was done too oh yeah when I came up gone
lashes off well you know you're going in
the middle of the ocean with your makeup
I don't
I'm not there to be in the water I'm
there to take pictures
that's fair
a lot of people feel that way I think
yeah when you got designer bathing suit
so I'm sure they didn't make that for us
to be swimming in the water
how much you spend on a bathing suit
will you say a designer bathing suit
like I feel like that's an impractical
thing to get designer
a bathing suit it's like when when
people buy their children like Gucci
clothes it's like what are you doing
like that's cool like you could get a
fashion over bathing suit yeah I wear
those too it's like you know no they're
not fashion Nova is nice 18 dollars for
no bathing suit I
don't I don't know they don't went up in
the prices I just feel like sometimes
when people buy designer certain things
I'm just like you're gonna get it wet
like it's going in the ocean like it's
going in the pool but it's not for that
you're not supposed that's not what
you're supposed to do I mean what's the
most uh ridiculous designer item that
you own did someone buy you an expensive
bag or do you have like a Gucci
toothbrush no it's this hat it's this
Burberry hat sounds ugly yeah and it is
and somebody convinced me that it was
just the coolest thing in the world and
it's not it's been I literally put it on
once and I never wore it again it's like
a Burberry hat and it looks like a
regular hat but it's a like a visor in
front of your face like you can't even
see like you don't know who it is in
front of you like at all and you know
yeah some people
can't wear the designer the designer
wears them
you see those people yeah they're just
like overly matched everything and it's
just like what's happening we get it
yeah you know anyway uh all right so the
new songs out area codes yeah lots of
remixes a little Tyler remixes on the
way sexy red on the way mellow books on
the way what's the uh wildest line sexy
red says on your remix
um she says something like she got hoes
tricks swamps thoughts but I'm trying to
figure out what what wamps is oh yeah I
gotta ask her that maybe you could ask a
whomp yeah wamps
no that's the Miami have you heard the
slap Me Out remix
no
that's a wild song they was talking
about it though have you heard the
original
um no oh
Anna Lee choppa's oh he's a wild boy man
I was talking to him at the studio the
other night I was like bro you're like a
child talking about getting your Gooch
played with bruh oh my God he said that
yes look at my gooch when you suck me
out
I know me out
that song's gold shots of Italy
chocolate I was laughing because how you
said it like wow I didn't think I'd ever
hear like a rapper to say the word Gooch
in a song and it Go gold but that's why
Anna Lee chop is amazing shout out to
him how old is he
I think he's 18. he might be 19 now
he's a he's a young old man though if
you've ever met him
and you should put him on a remix he's
got all those explicit boxes I think I
met him before but like oh I have met
him at fat during Fashion Week he was
really cool but he's quiet sweetheart
yeah he was really quiet he was really
cool he told me I would I did really
good at my performance the last thing
when I heard area codes I had a question
about one of the lyrics
now do you say drop your load or drop
your low
drop that [__] location that's what I
said okay no but it says you say you say
low and then you're like location no no
I said drop I said drop the low and I
said drop that [__] location okay
okay I'm gonna make sure when you said
drop the low you weren't saying drop the
load I'm like how many children why
would I I don't know with these these
days I got I have six children six
I'm just playing I have none I have none
I have no children I was just playing
but if you got six kids at 22 God bless
you yeah I was shout out to Grandma she
probably got her hands full no no I
don't have no kids not yet one day one
day one day appreciate you coming
through yeah uh new singles coming new
remixes I'm sure you're gonna have a
busy rest of the year tour maybe yeah
hopefully there it is thanks for coming
through Callie thank you